today on our show one is the loneliest
number that you'll ever see it's just me
and the fat cave with it news nothing
but news today family I'm Batman
[Music]
hey gang what's missing that guy Kevin
is off doing Kevin things I'm not
entirely sure where he is it could be
Canada it could be Montana could be
Indiana there's there was some territory
with an A at the end of it where he is
but he will be back shortly
but because I realized we all realized
it had been quite a long while since we
got together and talked about things
that I would just sort of just pop out
of fat cave just light up the old
electric fireplace and talk about little
news because there's news this week
there's a there's a ton of news the
first of which is not good news per se
but we lost Bill Paxton our AP bill
paxton I don't know about you guys what
your first exposure to the Paxton was
but my first exposure to Bill Paxton was
I think the world's first exposure to a
Paxton which was the punk in Terminator
hooah costs almost watsonater while he's
naked at Griffith Observatory and even
in that scene it's like two minutes long
he's got like a line in half but you
could tell there was this weird energy
to this guy this sort of livewire that
was both unpredictable and dedicated to
to conveying this sense of jittery
outsider eNOS I would then later see him
as many would in lots of James Cameron
productions but aliens and not a James
Cameron production but weird science as
Chet liked their there was a world in
which if you saw that Bill Paxton was in
a movie you knew that the movie would be
watchable nobody's gonna say they're all
going to be good but there would be
something in that movie that was
redeemable and worth recommending to
your friends and half the time that
thing was Bill Paxton today March 6th
when we were recording this the news
came out there was complications from a
heart attack a stroke
pardon my part of my French that he had
had a heart valve replacement and
something went wrong and infection
whatever unclear but what is clear is
that we lost Bill Paxton way too soon
there's there should be at least 20 more
years of bill paxton being the best
thing in any movie you see him in but
alas we are robbed of such glory and
wonder as as Bill Paxton could often
bring to the audience is near and far so
yes our ep Bill Paxton
we will fondly think of you urinating
yourself in True Lies which might not be
the way you want us to remember you but
however we get there we get there so yes
our people Paxton other news david
harbor from stranger things is in talks
apparently to play cable in deadpool 2
now if you like me have seen Logan and
Kevin and I will talk about Logan at a
later date but you saw the teaser the
mini little fancy awesome film in the
beginning of Logan spoilers to the
people in the house who haven't seen it
yet but it does open with like a trailer
teaser for Deadpool 2 it's happening
it's they're shooting it's all gonna go
down not in the DMS but in the DPS wait
a minute that's dirty
but yes David Harbor who was so amazing
in stranger things as the sheriff and
who gave the best speech of the Golden
Globes I believe with the sags the sags
is what that was
isn't toxically cable maybe a little
younger than I might have thought but if
you gray up the dudes hair like he can
pretend to be young Stephen Lang and who
is really who should be cable but we'll
go with that because we like David
Harvey would like stranger things for
you things season 2 coming soon so
that's happening Alexander siddig is a
name that I know very well from deep
space 9 when he was too big elf a deal
before he changed his name to Alexander
it was dr. Bashir and D space 9 he was
the Prince of Dorne in Game of Thrones
and he's now going to be Ra's al Ghul
and Gotham or race depending on how you
pronounce it I'm going Ross cuz that's
how I read it on the graphic novels back
of a day apparently
Ra's al Ghul is the character who's been
in the most incarnations of Batman
Beyond
man being Gotham he's on arrow he was in
Dark Knight he also showed up in the
animated series probably every animated
incarnation in this series but so now we
have an actual middle-eastern person
playing an actual middle-eastern
character which is kind of kind of
amazing and he's a fantastic actor he
really is he's he is there's a there's a
level of both empathy and intelligence
to that guy that when you combine them
can can either yield this sort of
ruthlessness but also a sort of
heartfelt sense of just reckless
intelligence which is one of my favorite
elements to a character and it's
something that you absolutely need if
you're gonna play the the demon himself
the detectives chief adversary granted
it would be nice if you know Ra's al
Ghul was fighting Batman
in Gotham but I don't think that's
happening
does it still baby Bruce Wayne but hey
it looks like the world is trying to
conspire to give me reasons to watch
Gotham again so I'll give Gotham a try
just to see what this guy does
so yes by all means that that is a happy
casting happy casting speaking of
castings they are rebooting Tron again
for reasons that surpasses understanding
but yet Disney is taking another go
after Tron Legacy which was twenty years
after Tron and not counting the awesome
Tron uprising TV show and Jared Leto
your third favorite Joker isn't talks to
star in a Tron reboot for Disney there's
no writer there's no director it is
super early stages but in case you
really love Jared Leto oscar-winning
Jared Leto he might be in a Tron near
you in a theater near you at some point
I don't know how I feel about that I
mean I was not a fan of his Joker
she could probably gather I think he was
fantastic in Dallas buyers club I think
he's really strong
in Fight Club as the beautiful thing
that needs to get destroyed but I still
don't know if he's an actual movie star
in a way that can hold the center of a
thing like Tron and I don't know that I
need another Tron either but hey these
are all things that are happening these
are all things that Disney thinks we
want so you know and how Disney has not
rolled the dice in bad ways very often
as of late so I will give anything that
promises to give me more light cycles a
chance even though I'm not sure that I
needed more light cycles in a much more
interesting casting note oma coming
[ __ ] to Star Wars
Michael Kate Williams who was Omar in
the wire has just joined the Han Solo
standalone movie directed by those two
dudes Miller and Lord I have not been as
excited about a casting since Donald
Glover got cast in the Han Solo
standalone movie but that actor is
outstanding I had there's no there's no
sense of what he's playing yet it's all
very hush-hush and on the Qt but that
dude is magnetic on screen and I will
watch him do anything and so for him to
get to play in a galaxy far far away a
long time ago is is a really exciting
prospect
so yes Omar and Han Solo are gonna be
rolling together in the distant past
slash future so that's outstanding news
we had talked a couple weeks ago about
Matthew Reeves taking over the Batman
film and it was then just in talks and
there were conversations and Kevin and I
spent a lot of time talked about whether
or not Ben would stick around where the
Matt Reeves would do it whether he
should do it he's a talented filmmaker
with a vision the reasons why it might
make sense to completely use that as an
excuse to reboot the entire DC EU and
then in the interim Matt Reeves fell out
of the project because apparently he
couldn't come to terms as far as control
over what that film would be and then he
did come back on the project for good so
yes Matt Reeves is directing the Batman
and producing it and I think he's having
a certain standalone element of control
to it that uh that gives him a little
bit more primacy over what that film
gets to be and as we said before like
Matt Reeves super talented guy like war
for the Planet of the Apes is coming
this summer or maybe even spring I mean
they're they're rolling out that summer
movies earlier and earlier every year so
but it's coming shortly and I'd like
I've liked what he's done almost all the
time so I see no reason why his take on
the Batman couldn't also be stellar so
yes just confirming a thing that fell
apart after we confirmed it to begin
with because time is on our side why not
right
finally Kevin and I will talk about this
more when he's back
along with our conversations about Logan
and various and sundry movie trailers
but there's gonna be a Nightwing
standalone movie directed by the dude
who made the Lego Batman movie Chris
McKay
Nightwing that's cool right like I could
be funny I mean there's a world in which
you don't not having to deal with the
the overwhelming sometimes punishing
seriousness of the Dark Knight can still
give you some humor to it and Chris
McKay has absolutely a sense of humor
after doing the Lego Batman movie even
like that that feels like he could add
this sort of tonal shift a little bit of
a sue song of levity in a world that has
had precious little levity but yeah I'm
curious about it and I'm interested to
see the choices they make in the cast
they offer but yeah like I I do sort of
feel in my heart of hearts that the DC
extended universe could use both levity
and if you even going a little bit
larger than that I reset and a reboot in
a sort of clean break from what has gone
before
a bit of a rethink not sure if a
Nightwing film helps you or hinders you
when doing that I'm not sure if between
Matt Reeves on the Batman and now a
Nightwing thing gives you a sense of
we're kind of starting fresh and by the
time you get after once you get through
Justice League on Aquaman then these
will be the new blood and like Phase two
which hopefully will be less grim than
phase one but I don't know these are all
questions that I'm just posing to the
universe we'll see what happens but it
is it's exciting news and a fat cave
that they're making more Battin Universe
films that is all the news we have this
week I didn't want to talk a little bit
about a movie that I did see that if you
haven't seen you positively should see
which is get out that's not it or you
could stay in your couch or wherever you
are but if you have not already seen get
out you should go see get out the debut
film from former half of the Godhead
behind key and Peele Jordan Peele
making its writing directing debut it's
it is a stunning piece of both its that
it's not quite a horror movie it's more
of a thriller but it is a stunningly
executed thriller that is also about
something and the thing that it's about
is race which is a hard thing for any
sort of mass media to tackle in a very
mature way let alone to make a horror
film for which race is is definitely a
major undercurrent that's shot through
it but it is an incredibly savvy film
that looks at the main character is a
black guy named Chris played by an
amazing actor named Daniel Kahlua with
British actors doing a positively
convincing American accent but like I in
New York he's in an interracial
relationship with Allison Williams from
girls and she is taking him home to her
to meet her parents for the first time
all of this you'd gather from the
trailer already and you've probably also
gathered from the trailer that when they
get to the Connecticut house that she's
from where Bradley Whitford is her
father and Catherine
as her mother weird [ __ ] goes down and
it's the kind of weird [ __ ] that it
functions on two levels the weird [ __ ]
is you know both a a stranger in a
strange land of this you know black kid
who lost his mom when he was very young
and if not grew up by himself but then
still grew up without much of a family
unit behind him grew up in the city is
now in what are absolutely the kind of
lily-white suburbs of Connecticut and
what that feels like to be the only
person who looks like you in any place
and the discomfort that can come with
that but it's also about a sense of
wrongness and at what point do does that
sense of wrongness outweigh your sense
of propriety it reminded me a little bit
of Rosemary's Baby Jordan Peele has
absolutely said that I was influenced on
him for this film the Stepford Wives
another influence but there's a movie
that came out last year called the
invitation by Karyn Kusama
which is about this this house party
whether this couple throws and the this
couple new boyfriend the ex-wife of the
main character invited him to this party
in the Hollywood Hills and it is a
series of uncomfortable encounters and
the movie works very hard and
successfully in explaining why your main
characters don't automatically leave the
[ __ ] house because it's the things
that are happening are beginning to add
up to the math is horrifying and the
solution of this equation is not good
for anybody
this feels that same way you're invited
to somebody's house weird [ __ ] is
happening but you roll with it because
it would be awkward and socially inept
for you to leave
even though leaving would be the best
thing you can do it's expertly acted get
out its expertly directed it's it's a it
manages the tension like a master and it
has something to say and I saw this
theater I saw it in the theater
with a bunch of coworkers all of which
were white
and I was the lone black guy and to a
person they all said that they did not
feel indicted by the film it was not a
film that is about my God look how
horrible white people are that's not
what that is it's a film about how
horrible these white people are
specificity and we've talked about that
before almost every time we talk about
movies specificity is the thing that
gets you there and this is a very
specific story about these specific
people who have a very specific kind of
horror that that plays incredibly well
in the story that is trying to tell I
cannot recommend it highly enough and
it's kind of amazing to me that we are
in the first week of March and we've
already seen two films that will end up
on a year-end list between get out and
Logan like I said we'll talk about that
later but those two films can absolutely
hold any spot on your top 10 films of
the year and to get them so early it's
kind of amazing
I mean Logan Logan my god it's full of
stars no I mean Logan Logan would be
your top ten in the other year no matter
when it came out Logan is probably in
the top five superhero films of all time
but yeah Kevin and I will absolutely
dissect it next time we sit down but we
you should absolutely go see get out and
for all I know you already have the
movie made some like thirty million
dollars its opening weekend which is a
hit it's not Logan money which made 88
million dollars its opening weekend but
for a five million dollar Blum House the
horror film by a first-time director
with a mostly unknown star thirty
million dollars is nothing a [ __ ]
sneeze at so more of you have probably
seen it then then I think but if not go
do it
come find me tell me what you thought so
that's it for this week that's the news
that we got that's a little bit of a
maybe review of a movie next time I
think we might have a guest in this air
fat cave while Kevin is still traveling
the world learn
Kung Fu as rich white guys do but when
he comes back he will teach us the ways
of the iron fist and we will have much
longer conversations about Logan and the
awesomeness to come so that's it for
this week I'm mark Barnard and the fat
cave come back same fat time same fat
channel SModcast calm or youtube.com
slash Kevin Smith thanks for playing
with me all by myself as I play with
myself
[Music]
you
[Music]